hey guys and welcome back to the layah heilpern
show powered by icon plus so icon is excited to
announce iconfi so it's a super easy staking um
and earning service where you can receive yield
on icon ethereum bitcoin tether and if you do join
early you can actually get up to twenty percent
fixed term and apy so always great news coming out
of icon there i also want to say thank you to my
sponsors block five so as you guys probably know
already i use them um i earn up to 8.6 interest
on my usdc uscc is a stable coin pegged to the us
dollar so there you go um if you're interested in
that um you can actually get i think at the moment
around 250 dollars if you join so i'll leave a
link for that in the comments in the description
in all the places you go to find a link so i'll
leave that there um and before we start the show
because i do have a very very exciting guest um i
also want to say a quick shout out to coinflip so
coinflip are doing some incredible work across the
states to push bitcoin mass adoption they have
nearly a thousand atms um across 45 different
states um giving everybody access to bitcoin so
i think that's some incredible stuff that they're
doing so today i have a really cool guest somebody
who is actually i'm not sure if you know this um
one of my favorite people in the space it is c
z how are you doing hello how are you i'm good
how are you pretty good pretty good i didn't
know i didn't know that your favorite person
you are and let me tell you why you're one of my
favorite people in this way so i think you know a
lot of the time these big ceos big founders they
i find that there's quite like a distance between
them and the community and there's not that
interaction that you that you would like and i
find that you're one of the most i mean loads of
people say this you're one of the most um active
people on on twitter and you reply to people we
can interact with you and i think it's such a
small community so it kind of seems odd when there
isn't that connection do you know what i mean uh
yeah i think well for me it's really interesting
as well so um i learned a lot from our users it's
a good way for me to interact actually i'm not a
socializing hub so like many people like some hubs
know a lot of people i actually don't know that
many people so i don't really socialize with that
many people but i just find it easy on twitter to
talk to our users and talk to our community just
talk to our supporters it's just it's just easy so
um yeah for me it's pretty it's pretty simple yeah
no it's really nice and you know as somebody in
the space i mean i totally appreciate it and i
know loads of people do appreciate it as well um
but i've got loads of questions for you because
loads of people know you as cz the guy from
finance and all this stuff but i want to know
more about you so how would you define yourself um
so yeah i mean i would just think of myself as a
ex-developer turned entrepreneur um kind of have
a little bit of an international experience in my
early days and then got lucky had a really strong
team that executed well and then now i have a
chance to to help increase the freedom of money
all around the world and this is a this is a great
opportunity i'm really i'm really humbled by it so
that's that's who i am so i'm doing doing my thing
yeah absolutely you are doing your thing
and you're obviously very successful
and you know even before crypto you were doing a
lot of stuff in tech so give me three principles
that you would say you've learned from all
of this that you can sort of take with you
and i guess people who are also looking to get
into crypto looking to maybe do something like
yourself what are three main principles um i
think for me um i think the first principle
from for myself i do have a couple principles
i could share um yeah but like i don't know i
don't know if the principles will really help or
not but i i do try to be fair in life uh so uh
where whatever business partner we work with i
do like this might sounds cheesy we do try to
uh uh structure win-win deals um i do view
most uh corporations to be long-term so uh
we want to be long-term uh successful we only we
want to be long-term benefiting a long-term deal
typically you wanted to work on for both
sides because otherwise it's not going to last
same thing as when we hire when we hire people
who work in the in the team and when we work
with external people et cetera so also when how we
treat our users our community et cetera so um so
i think trying to be fair is probably the first
principle that i really recommend people and i
do try to follow that fairly strictly myself i
don't i never try to take advantage of people
um i also don't try to let people take advantage
of us but um sometimes it happens but that's okay
i think that's the first one the second one
is probably just being really really focused
so i try to remove all distractions anything
that's not really important so i have no car i
don't have to take care of insurance fixing cars
parking i don't have to worry about all of that
um i don't really have a lot of time consuming
hobbies um so i don't really play games anymore
um so i just really and i don't have any external
investments outside of finance i never invest
personally finance as an organization investing in
different type of organizations and we have a team
to do that so i don't have anything personally i
don't have any personal investments i don't even
have a house anymore so i keep everything very
simple when i go to a restaurant i if if i
couldn't pick up something i like in the first
five seconds i just pick the third item on the
menu so i try to make it more yeah so i just try
to make everything really really simple so that i
can focus on one thing which is binance right now
so um so so that's that's the second principle so
i remove a lot of the distractions that most
people may have the third one is probably in
this industry just got to be really positive so
number one is we being positive and being fair is
slightly different so we we never tried to target
anyone we're not against anyone any organization
any government any regulator we would we're not
into that um and we're just trying to build value
which we're just trying to try to contribute
whatever we can into like this may sound
kind of cheesy but honestly we're just trying to
contribute to this industry contribute to society
um we if we if we don't have that such strong
abilities then we'll just contribute a little bit
if now we can contribute a little bit more so um
so just being positive and also on a day like this
being positive is pretty important so i would
say that's probably the three things i would i
would say that are really important to me and
i try to follow them to the best extent i can
yeah i think those things things are really
important and it's not cringy in the slightest
it's not cliche um i think that's insane
so you don't have a car and you don't have
an actual house that you own essentially no
i don't i don't have a car don't have a house
it's my life is much simpler so
i don't have to take care of i
had a house at one point it took me six months
to sell it it was like so much trouble so i now
i don't have to worry about it i just you know
i rent um i live in hotels it's fine oh my gosh
you know that's really interesting because they
sort of say that is the new world there's this
idea that you've got to get on the property ladder
but that seems to be this old kind of mentality
i think it depends on lifestyle so if you live in
one place uh for a while i think having a place
is good and if you have like you know raising
kids and stuff like that um but for me like i
travel so much and even if i even if i buy
a house or car i'm not going to be using 90
of the time it's just gonna sit there and rust
and then like i'm still gonna be using uber um
grab and all this other uh ride sharing services
i'm still gonna be staying in hotels et cetera so
um for me it doesn't it doesn't really help and it
just creates a lot of mental baggage that i need
to take care of i yes for me it's much easier
without those things yeah i absolutely hear you
i think that's really interesting and i think
i'm definitely gonna consider that um because
i'm always moving around as well and you know i'm
thinking houses cars and this but you mentioned
something really interesting you said not to
be taken advantage of and being fair so i wanna
i wanna learn a little bit more about this because
i think you know not just in work but in life in
general there's this really difficult line between
sort of being fair being honest and being kind um
and then that kindness and can sort of be taken
for granted and or can be mistaken for weakness
so how do you find that line i think number one
is like for anybody i interact with personally
or have a work relationship of any kind either
they're working with part as part of binance or
as a partner with binance etc we do we do try
to structure deals that work for both sides so
once like for example if i if my team member says
it's easy we got this really good deal to work
with this other entity um and this is why it's so
good for us i always ask why is it good for them
um so i need to understand that deal structure so
that it's good for both sides it makes sense so
um yeah things have to make sense and then um um
i i believe that look if if the other party asks
for a lot that we don't think is fair then we just
walk away um it's a free world in most places um
so we just walk away and we try not to be taking
advantage advantage of um there are certain times
where we do have to defend ourselves a little bit
and by sometimes even like fighting back a little
bit but like that's you that if for binance or
for myself that's all that's almost always because
somebody attacked us first first so when those
things happen then we have no choice but um it's
not something we want to do it's not something i
enjoy but look um sometimes you have to so yeah
yeah and speaking and speaking of fair and and all
of that i think you can absolutely sort of like
hold your word to that because i remember
you guys were hacked was it in 2019 and
it was like that seven bitcoin reserves
or whatever it was i don't remember but
you had that reserves and you were able to
you know give that back to your customers
yes so um yeah so we always we always we we always
want to protect our users and be fair being very
fair to them so if we get hacked that's our
responsibility we should cover it and also
two years ago there was a hacker that attacked us
and then we put out a bounty that's kind of like a
aggression from us but we were attacked first
and we actually um we just granted that bounty
like 250k us dollars worth of um i think they
took bnb um so we just granted that recently
and um so that's that's uh because uh the
somebody was actually uh two guys actually helped
us track those guys down and through proper legal
procedures they were actually put on some sanction
list um so that's not that's not a situation where
we had to defend ourselves by putting out a bounty
to hunt for some hackers but we would not we would
not aggressively do we would not proactively do
that unless we're attacked so we were attacked two
years ago so yeah yeah you have to do what you got
to do to protect yourselves and your customers
i think you guys you know you show that you do
that but moving on a little bit i want to go back
to your early life and understand how you became
cz so you grew up in china but then you
moved to canada and from what i've read
your father was a professor who was exiled
from china so if you don't mind me asking
i'm really interested to know what happened sure
um yeah so i can go a little bit more detail than
what i went through previously so
probably people here a little bit more
um so i become cz because most people can't really
pronounce my name very well so so that's probably
why um but um so i um i was born in china i moved
to canada uh with my parents when i was 12. and at
the time my father was a professor so my father's
life is actually pretty interesting so my father
um my father got into university and the first
year he got into into university was the cultural
revolution in china so they basically canceled all
universities and said look go back to the farmland
learn the core values of life learn how to
find farm land um and my father came from
like the countryside so um so um uh of uh six
years later he didn't attend a single class
he was trying to study on his own and then um
after the cultural revolution he applied for
a um a master's degree in university of british
british columbia so that's in vancouver canada
and um so he got he actually got accepted because
he was studying on his own so my father is kind of
a bookworm and then he went to continue to study a
master program and then a phd um so my father was
always like a like a student of some type and then
eventually became like a professor um so i uh when
i went to canada um he was still that was just
before he got his phd phd degree this is when i
was 12. so we were living on his master's program
uh um i don't know salary or or or or professor
income uh not professor like the pro his professor
was giving him some like income so it wasn't much
um it was not we were not super poor but we're
not rich by any means so like we were we were
we were like friendly very very modest so that's
kind of like my my sort of growing up that's my
father's um um that's kind of my father's um like
his life in a very you know very you know very
a very simplified version so my father's always a
brokeworm um and he he's always like academic uh
never good not very good in business but he's like
always just sort of you know lived a very simple
life so i kind of i came i kind of came from that
my father did encourage me to work from very early
on um so i worked at mcdonald's was my first job
i think i was 14 15. um so that was actually under
the legal age of working in canada which is 16
but mcdonald's has some kind of has some kind
of exception that they are they do they are able
to take young young kids young teenagers to work
and that was a really really good experience
so um i i worked really early and then um
um and then i basically had different jobs ever
since then um not continuously when i was like in
school when i was like in college in school like
when i studied a study and then this in the summer
i i worked so i've traveled quite a lot even
myself so i moved in china and then moved to
canada and then went to in canada moved into
different places so i was always like i never
really stayed in one city for very long um and i
was moving between countries as well so when i was
um in college um my my second intern job i went
to japan tokyo to work so i was like traveling
in different countries so i think that
international um experience actually really
really helped me now before i never really i never
realized how valuable that was but by looking back
now having that international sort of exposure uh
really helped me to get into crypto understanding
understand bitcoin understand cross-border
remittances transactions so yeah i mean a lot yeah
you know short version like kind of long already
but um but that but that's kind of what shaped
me in my early years yeah i think you make two
really interesting points right so it's kind of
moving from country to country you your family and
you probably both experienced the issue you know
with money it's an absolute nightmare having to
you know change your money here change your money
there you can't get a bank account and all this
stuff um so i think that's actually insane because
you probably really felt that growing up and now
you know you're one of the biggest people in this
space driving it forward you know so you must have
really felt the need for that um but then as well
you know you're obviously really international
um you know i often find that i often find that
a lot of the time people who haven't left their
own country and for whatever reason sort of
unfortunately lack a certain kind of world view
just because they haven't had the opportunity
to see anything else um so you know when you're
working in this space and you're dealing with
all these different people um yeah you know
you've had that experience which which i think
is really cool but i'm interested in your father
what happened why why was he exiled from china
so he like wasn't really accident but basically
due to the cultural revolution he didn't spend a
single day in university and then when the
cultural revolution was over there was a
program for there was a trend or a program for
people to apply to go overseas especially for the
academics um and so my father applied and so it
was actually a pretty difficult process even for
my so you like well we can get into a little bit
more detail so my father went to canada in 1984.
um i went to canada six years later five six
years later in 1989. um there was a little bit
of history there as well so um so my father went
on a student visa and then in china back then it
was very difficult to get a passport so it took
like almost i remember it took like three or four
years for us to get a passport and once you have
a passport it's extremely difficult to get a visa
so like visa was very very limited back then um
but then in 1989 there was a tmn square event
where the student was protest and there were some
uh some issues and right after that that incident
um the foreign the foreign government relaxed the
visa require restrictions and there was there was
like lines around the canadian embassy in beijing
like it circles the embassy like and you have to
wait for two days to get it so basically you let
you you wait for 48 hours on the street like with
a with a chair with a plastic chair and everything
but um but they they were granting visas so um i
got my visa i was 12 i was following my mom so i
got my visa in that process um and then got the
visa and so um so the the 1984 uh student event is
on june 4th and i left china in on on august 9th
so i remember those days really clearly
because those are pretty significant events
and so that actually taught me some really
interesting experiences where like moving
between countries etc you don't really live
in one country there's a world out there
so my father um my father so when i went when i
went to canada he was still just finishing up his
phd thesis so i remember attending his thesis
just look watching him talk and stuff like that
so he already had a 12 year or 12 year old kid
and um so i couldn't really understand very much
but i kind of unders i kind of i got a gist of
it um and then um so my father just always had
more academic jobs like never never
he was never an entrepreneur so he
um so he he was always like an academic academic
guy um so let a pretty simple life um yeah so
that's that's kind of yeah afterwards yeah he
he afterwards once he got a phd degree and then
he settled down and he eventually went to work
um for uh he studied dual physics so like um so
basically like crazy integration formulas um to
figure out how where the oils are uh under on
under under under the under the earth so he worked
for a couple of oil companies he actually went to
texas uh houston to um to work for a couple oil
companies and then went back to canada so um so he
actually had a he always had a more of a academic
position yeah so that's kind of my father and
just like going back a little bit the most
interesting thing well it's all super interesting
but something which really really stood out to me
um was the job position as a mcdonald's employee
at 14. so that's insane because number one just
look at you know how much you've achieved since
then but also you know you are like under under
the working age like you said the working age
was 16. so when you're working in mcdonald's um
because you know people it's really awful but
i mean i don't know if you have the obviously i'm
from the uk and there's this stupid joke in the uk
about people working at mcdonald's it's just
that's just the joke that there is in the uk
i don't know if it's a global thing i have no
idea um but you know when you're working there
did you ever think that you would be able to
achieve what you've achieved and you know be
one of the most successful people in such a
growing space and also absolutely like you
just can't knock people working at mcdonald's i
think you know working from 14 that's just insane
good on you yeah so i never really thought i
would be a billionaire i just never crossed my
mind even like even like four years ago just like
any any time before four years ago even before
three and a half years ago just never crossed my
mind um so i never had such strong uh ambitions
but i i i do know that i want to be financially
free but not maybe not at that age using that that
term but i at that at that time i probably just
thought i want some more pocket money to buy some
to buy some stuff that i want to buy um
but uh i do know that i do i need to work
for i do need i need to work for for uh for
money what's interesting though is um at my
age uh so my my dad is a pretty unique case in
uh and i was a pretty unique case in canada um
at the time most of the people most of people
from from mainland china to canada like a
student immigrates they're much younger so they're
like 27 20 something my father's 40 40 something
approaching 50s so i was 12. and um so it's either
like yeah like 20 something like university grads
et cetera applying for master's student students
and they have kids that are much younger it's like
maybe like just babies so there's no no very few
kids from like at age 12 in canada at that time
so my friends were um they were they were asians
they were like taiwanese guys and uh hong kong
cantonese hong kong guys um in in vancouver
there's a lot of them they they do speak chinese
and uh and then there's the sort of caucasians
to canada's immigrant country right so there's
people from everywhere from the world so i'm i was
very tuned into the international sort of uh scene
i was so this is also why i'm very comfortable
getting used to uh talking to people around
different parts of the world and then there's uh
but the uh the taiwanese guys and the cantonese
guys they all they were all investing immigrants
so their parents are usually like investing a
couple million dollars in canada and then um
to get the citizenship and uh the taiwan guys
typically their their parents are doctors in
taiwan in taiwan they're making very decent
money they usually buy like a couple million
dollar house in canada and usually invest in some
business to get the to get the visa so they they
were relatively rich so um those guys are driving
like really nice cars not super nice but like you
know volvo's sometimes porsche um so i i wasn't
able to afford a car when i when i was a like
when i turned 16 got my driver's license i wasn't
so for me like i was like i was you know very i
was on on a very modest uh financial situation
where like a lot of my friends are relatively well
off so i had that that little bit of a comparison
but i i never thought of becoming a billionaire
but i just wanted to sort of be financially just
sort of be well off and not like uh i didn't want
to be ranked super high but just right well off
so that's kind of the um the environment
where's that or at least the way i remember
some of my some of my early mentality but
kudos to uh a lot of my friends from then
many of those kids worked in mcdonald's as well
so the the guys i have with like the taiwanese
guys cantonese guys the caucasians they worked
in mcdonald's as well um so like some of the
guys were driving porsche to mcdonald's i love it
i love it that's brilliant that's so brilliant um
so you mentioned financial freedom right so
like that's this fancy term that we love to use
um but you know back in the day what did financial
freedom actually mean to you did it just mean the
ability to sort of like drive your porsche to
mcdonald's uh and i'm joking or do or did it
just sort of mean like literally you know own your
own assets um i think i only understood that term
much much later to be honest so now like um so
back then it was just really just to earn some
pocket money um so that yeah just hang out with
friends etc um and um uh much later on i would say
like when i was starting to getting jobs like from
when i was in university like getting intern jobs
i was i started to reach that poor dad um and
then thought about walking what does financial
freedom mean um so uh i i learned about passive
income at a relatively early age as well so i was
looking at how so how do i generate like so that's
the reach that part of that book um but then um
like i think uh even until when i was 30 something
i think that's kind of when i slowly kind of had
a relatively stable financial situation et cetera
so uh and then i think back then i would say look
if even if you have if you ask me four years ago
if you ask me what financial freedom means i would
say probably like five to ten million dollars
is probably enough for most for me for most
people um look if you have 10 million dollars
above 10 million dollars you're not going to
need you're not going to spend all that money um
well like depending on what you do you could yeah
yeah but like to live to to maintain to maintain a
pretty decent living standard you don't you don't
need that much well 10 million is not a it's not a
small amount so so that's kind of how like like i
didn't really understand it at that young age but
like later on that's kind of even four years ago
that would be my that would be my standard
so you know that's only four years ago and
bitcoin is i mean what do we call it 12 years
old now more or less 12 years old yeah so what do
you think your life would have looked like if you
know bitcoin had never been invented i mean i know
you were obviously in tech anyway and you were
already making huge moves anyway for yourself but
what would your life have looked like you
know if bitcoin would never be invented
i don't know um yeah that's a that's a very
tough one in a kind of a hypothetical situation
i don't know i probably would try some like i
knew i knew i knew i'm a startup guy um so um
after working at large companies i i was like
no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be able to work
in large companies um it's just it's just
a bit too slow um so i i i would i would be
probably uh doing some tech startup and
maybe like today maybe ai i tried social
media i didn't didn't do anything there uh
i didn't do anything successful there um so
probably today would be some like some ai stuff
probably a struggling entrepreneur um who knows
yeah i mean sorry i just wanted to unmute my mic
it's quite loud here um but i mean and you also
mentioned passive income and i think that's
really an interesting point because passive
income is sort of something which i think
everybody can achieve um but not everybody
knows how to achieve it so how did you have
that penny sort of drop moment just because
people often think they have to trade time for
dollars but that's not quite the case is it no
that's absolutely not the case so basically today
uh well in chinese desert there's a very simple
saying if you're working for money um you have
a very you have you're a very limited ceiling
how much time you can work so even like
for example even if you have a very high
pay-per-vision profession like lawyers doctors
you learn decent you earn very decent money but
the minute you stop well you won't have savings
but the minute you stop working you stop earning
then that's not a very sustainable situation and
it's not scalable so um it's um so but of course
if your doctor you can you can start a clinic and
hire people but then the minute you hire somebody
to work as a team etc then then you're not only
working uh you're not only trading your time um
to to get money um and then if you if you
if you if you if you buy an apartment rent
it out then that's generating passive income
ideally you want the rent to be able to cover
your mortgage payments and so then this way
you have some positive cash flow and the more
the more of those situations you have the
better the better off you are and um um so
like um i talked a guy off buying an iphone
12 pro max like a couple days ago on twitter
the guy was debating between selling his uh bmb or
and to or or uh or to buy it to buy an iphone and
obviously because he was so recognizing on twitter
that there must be a pretty significant amount of
money for him i said look if it's a skin because
if it's that kind of significant portion of uh
amount of money for you don't buy a depreciation
depreciating asset right so you want to buy
something that's that has potential to appreciate
so um so that guy is a very very dedicated uh bmb
supporter so not not not difficult to talk
him off that at all um um and then the bmd
price dropped today so hopefully he's still no
i'm sure he's okay he's a long-term holder so
um so he's okay and uh but uh i think people
need to understand that passive income uh is
really important like uh the minute that you have
something generating income for you or potentially
have uh gains for you that you don't have to work
yourself the more of those you have the better
um so that's really really important so i think
a lot of people don't understand that and they
just like they they spend they trade their time to
for for for money and then they spend it um that's
that's a very limited way to uh to to achieve
financial freedom and that's a very hard way
to achieve financial freedom yeah i'm totally
with you and you know sort of generating that
passive income is something which i've sort of
only recently come across i mean i'm only in my
20s so it's something which um that idea has
recently just popped out and i'm sort of like
learning more about it and understanding how i
can do that i think it's such a shame though that
um you know we're not sort of taught that there's
another way of doing things you know we're always
taught that we have to be in the system and you
know be a product of the system and work for the
industrialists and so on but i won't go on um
i want to know a little bit more actually about
binance so like you said you know you were sort of
intact before but where did the idea come from and
also where did the name come from uh okay so the
idea is the idea is really not a new idea i think
almost everybody i met in the crypto industry or
at least every entrepreneur i met in the crypto
industry wanted to start a cryptocurrency exchange
at some point um so the idea is really old
and talked about in 2013 um jonah joined the
exchange in 2014 and then left that exchange
they thought about starting a new exchange in 2015
um thought it was a bit early and then 2017 um
uh we thought that time was right um at the time
poloniex and blue tracks are doing really really
not not high volumes like in today's terms but
back then it was like pretty decent volumes
a couple hundred million dollars a day uh in in
trading volumes and they like back then i think
the fees much higher like they were like like
one percent or something so that so back then
the industry was like was not small uh already
so 2017 without the time was right um the name
binance came in 2017. i didn't have the name
before um so um we had a couple of different names
and then i actually did come up with a binary's
name um so like bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin finance
bid finance blockchain finance and then binary
finance binary and finance have the most overlap
in the number of letters um if we if we move it
if we replace the b with uh we if we replace the
f in finance with b so that's uh i came up with
that and then um uh the domain was was just sold
uh two months ago uh um so then uh we tried to
talk to the guy and then i think the guy actually
only charged us like a couple thousand dollars so
we got the domain so that's how it started at the
beginning i wasn't even sure about the name we had
a couple of different candidates really yeah um
but um worked out worked out okay so far so yeah
absolutely and also this is just like a side point
i also think the colors are fantastic absolutely
brilliant yellow and black like you guys are ahead
of the time yellow and black just from a branding
standpoint yellow and black are sort of like a new
a new duo um so i think i think you did
great on that but after launching in july
2017 so after eight months you guys actually
became the biggest exchange in crypto so
how did you do that that's something everybody is
trying to do i've got friends that are setting up
exchanges um but eight months wow yeah um so to
be honest when we first started we thought we
would get lucky we'll be lucky if we can get in
the top 10 within three years so that's kind of
the target that we had um so it's not that like we
wanted we we aimed for it right away and we wanted
to be the number one exchange in the world um but
so we didn't really we actually didn't really have
such uh as professional as professional goals or
like really ambitious goals but um i do think that
uh we just try to do what we're good at and while
we try to do our best to provide the best product
and service so it's really in my in my view it's
really really basic so when we first started um
there's really only two crypto there's many crypto
crypto exchanges but there's really two big ones
that's poloniex and b tracks and both of them uh
only have a pc version and even on the pc version
on the website if you want to trade you have
to scroll back and forth you have to look at
the price on top and then scroll to the bottom to
enter to enter numbers and then so it's not a very
in my view it's not a very good experience to
be honest um so we designed one full screen um
you don't have to scroll at all um you can see the
charts you can see the history trade so everything
you need to do is on that screen and you can trade
um so that's like a user experience optimization
and also um we really we launched the mobile
apps very quickly and we also made our website
work relatively well on mobile mobile web version
and also those two exchanges are only available in
english so basically they were located in the u.s
and they just service us users it's a big market
but we thought that's like well u.s
at 20 of the global gdp that's 80
gdp outside of of us so and we were based
in asia so we thought we want to target the
the other ones so we launched nine languages
very quickly and today we support 22 languages
so we're like like product wise we just thought
there was like a there's a lot of slack well
there's a lot of room there's a lot of like on
unclaimed territory that we can try so we did that
we also had a pretty we also had a very decent uh
matching engines really fast like it's noticeably
fast even when even even when you trade manually
price not already get a confirmation it's really
really fast so people like it um the other thing
is service so product and service is really basic
back in 2017 um if before binance if you submit
like if you submit a sport ticket on any of the
exchanges you're probably going to be waiting for
a month for the reply and this is when you have
money stuck on exchange or have some kind of issue
on financial platform basically so we thought
that's kind of extreme we can probably try to do
better it's actually pretty difficult to do um but
we did set a set a target of 20 maximum 24 hours
for the response ideally within within an hour
um and then we just hired a lot of guys um we we
wrote a lot of faqs we tried to make the system as
easy to understand as possible um and we were
servicing like like uh like a dozen languages
back then 22 languages now so it's it's difficult
but we we did we did do it and then actually after
that um a lot of other exchanges copied us so
now the service level in the industry is much
better which is good for everyone which is also
good for us because it brings more people in
um so we were also the first exchanges to
do a number of things like the um uh the gas
distributions like if one coin use another coin um
like they what what people could now call staking
or airdrops uh we were the first centralized
exchange to support that before that if you have
one coin who's generating another coin to change
that doesn't distribute that second coin to you
we thought that's a pretty simple mathematical
exercise that we can do that just distribute that
um so we did that um we did that first with neil
and that attracted a lot of the new uh community
to us so that's so there's a lot of little things
we did it's nothing too magical everything's like
pretty basic um and then just a lot of time
on twitter people seem to like it so um that's
interesting yeah well i told you i i told you i
told you twitter is you know people love it people
love you for interacting with them um but that
that's really interesting you're it's the little
things you know it's the little user experiences
it's that little little that can get my words out
can i it's the little touches that you do um and i
think that's really important and actually i love
to hear how um you know a free market competition
and all this stuff has sort of raised the bar
so like you said um now people respond within
24 hours because you guys set that standard
so that's super cool but with all of that going
on all these different languages and everything
how involved are you in the day-to-day runnings
of finance i'm really not that involved anymore
so like i can literally be off like i could turn
off my phone i could be off the internet for
probably like i don't know a week or a month and
binance will be totally fine um i think a lot of
users may panic because i don't know just just the
mentality but i'm no longer really involved on the
day-to-day operations um we have a really strong
team now the team size is not small either
we we just passed surpassed 1500 people globally
and including the angels the angels don't get paid
they don't get paid a salary so if including
the angels probably over 1800 people now so
it's a pretty large team um they're very very
self-sufficient uh with distributed teams so
every everybody does their own thing and somehow
it just works together so um i get i get i get
involved in things when we gotta make like a so
i don't even look at investment deals until the
last minute and they said look cece we're gonna
invest a couple million dollars here so like
okay sounds good um so uh and then i get
involved in like i get involved more like
uh i'm getting more and more now i'm trying to
learn more of this sort of um how to optimize
organizations um so i try to experience we
experiment with different different ways so i
do try to talk to people more um but just like
hey how's it going anything you want to talk
about not specifically hey you you need to do this
and that so i try to like talk to people just um
more just to just just to see what ways can we
optimize the organization but um like running mine
is like really not like the um and like normally
so what happens now when something happens at
minus like even today when there was some like lag
uh some data data center issues i just get told
what to tweet so just see you thing okay tweeting
it so uh yeah so i'm not i'm not really i'm not
really not involved on the day-to-day operations
now i have a leadership question actually um i
know that you're not fully involved in it now but
obviously you were so in terms of you know running
this successful business and this startup at the
time and really you know lifting it off the ground
how important well of course leadership is
important but what kind of leadership would you
say is important were you micromanaging were you
um did you empower people to sort of um you know
make them feel like valuable members of the team
what kind of ethos did you install in the company
yeah so um yeah i'm i was never micromanager
so i'm terrible at managing details um and um
i do give people a lot of freedom so i my my my
my style is like i give people a lot of freedom
um and um they can make mistakes they can they can
they can fail businesses they can fail projects
but as long as they as long as they work hard and
try hard so my ethos has always been giving people
a lot of freedom um and then um uh i do in the
early days i do set even today i still set the
sort of general direction where we're going like
what things we should do is should not do like
just more on the rules side not not specific tasks
and specific things but just okay look we should
never hurt our users so make it if this decision
involves um hurting our users or not then don't
it's pretty obvious um and then um i do think
that finding the right people is really really
important so getting the right team in place
and then making sure that they work together
well and making sure that the team is really
passionate and they um so i think getting the
right people in is really really important i
i do think i do do a decent job on that front
um and getting the organic right people
into the right seats i actually do less of
they want to get people in they find their
own seats um sometimes not ideal but then
whatever um i i don't spend a lot of time
on strategy so this is something that's uh
maybe a little bit counter-intuitive but for me
it was very clear this is the direction we're
going we don't we don't spend we don't spend
much time at all on discussing strategy stuff
um we we focus a lot more on execution so just
like how do we do this thing you know this is
where we want to go and how do we do this um so
not not so much on what we need to do or not but
more like a like like it's pretty easy to figure
out what to do but just how to do it um in the
early days well even i think even now i still do i
still i i believe i still do lead by example um i
even though i don't get involved but i i have
like uh somewhere between 15 to 16 calls every day
just like when just just conference calls just
phone calls to people um and then i um i work i
work relatively long hour i don't really call
it work i just view this part of my life yeah
so um yeah so i have calls at uh 11 p.m right now
it's like actually so now it's 10 p.m for me 10 45
p.m for me um so like but this is normal working
hour if i'm not talking to you i'll be talking to
somebody on my team or or doing something so even
though i don't get involved in the operations but
i do talk to people i i'm always online i'm always
i'm always around um so people see that and people
and the guys will report to me directly and
they all work those hours so the like uh i can
ping them like at one am um they usually usually
from like one to two until like seven or eight so
do those however sometimes we can't find them but
outside of those hours or we can always find them
um so um i do literally i do have a i believe
our team do have a very hard working uh
mentality so um i think the the the leaders
should set the tone uh for that um i think
there's no shortcut for hard work for hard work
so other than that yeah i think that's pretty much
yeah other than that i don't have a lot of other
sort of secrets or uh good things or or like um
wisdom yeah so yes i think it's pretty basic yeah
yeah i think um so so many interesting things that
you know you mentioned it's all about getting
the right people in and you know i i'm you know
i don't own a company like that obviously but you
know just from my personal experience within work
it's come it's so true it's so hard to find the
the right people that you fit with and you know
you share a vision and when you find them you
don't want to let them go and you have to sort
of like instill the right ethos so that they stay
and they have they help build something amazing
um so what's the vision for finance then for
finances i think it's pretty simple um uh so we
we really just want to help build infrastructure
in this industry so to help this industry grow
and the reason we want to do that is we we want to
increase the freedom of money so i i strongly and
i think our team all believes that um if you look
at history anytime that we increase we're able to
increase freedom of something without sacrificing
other things um the human civilization the the our
quality of life improves so from like freedom
from slavery freedom of speech freedom of press
um freedom of information um and um so anytime
we can increase those freedom but today we don't
we don't have a lot of freedom on money um uh we
get this all kind of problems i want to i won't
go into so that so that's that's kind of what we
want to try to grow this industry and we want to
build infrastructure to help people uh use crypto
more and have more access to crypto and right now
the biggest the biggest application is obviously
the exchange right now but we don't view that as
i don't think that's going to be always the case
there are many other infrastructure services that
could be potentially be built and provided and
we don't have to provide every single one of
them we want to provide a few good ones that we're
good at so potentially hopefully in the future i
don't know payments is a very obvious one that
hasn't really taken off to be honest um that's
a cross-border with cross-border remittances um
even gaming there's many different infrastructure
services that we can try uh we probably will
fail at a number of them hopefully we'll be
successful in a few um so that's kind of
the the the direction finance is going
i like that um you know just do a million
different things and one of them will stick
you know and just because yeah and you know and
it's kind of like when people start a company they
often say you know it doesn't matter if all of the
you know you started three or four companies and
they all failed your fourth one might be the one
which beats every company in the world so you just
don't know um but as a side point actually how did
you first hear about bitcoin i read a funny story
um apparently you sold at your house for one
million dollars um to put it all into bitcoin
in 2013 what on earth is going on here yeah so um
bobby lee who was the ct a ceo of btc china uh he
was just above joining btc china in 2013 uh that
was in like june july um so um i i played program
with him so um he he comes to my house to play
program actually him and he's um eventually later
on investor ron tao who's a managing director of
live speed in china um so we're playing poker um
and they were saying well okay now he's going
to quit his job from uh he has a pretty decent
job so he was going to quit his job to join the
startup with two guys um the two original founders
btc china he's going to become the ceo and this
they're running a bitcoin exchange uh and he says
cz you gotta you should buy you should you should
look into bitcoin and and in fact he said um
you should convert you should you should convert
ten percent of the net worth into bitcoin
um you may go to there's a there's a decent chance
you'll go to zero i think so you lose ten percent
uh there's a higher chance you will go 10x so then
you double um so okay that's pretty serious uh so
so then i started looking into it and um so and
then ron runs how light speed ventures invested
in btc china pumping 5 million dollars back then
a pretty large sum for the industry back then
and then um so i was like okay that's pretty
serious so i started reading about bitcoin um
started reading about repo actually uh uh ron was
also like looking at a report and i said i should
look into it i did um and then so i really liked
it and then um but uh the thing uh so that was
like july starting july i was investing a little
bit so i was buying a little tiny bit i was like
i bought like one bitcoin which where did you
buy from uh actually i bought it i bought it on
btc china actually um it was it was really hard
getting money in and then i also bought it i also
used mongoox among us at the fiat channel um in
japan um so actually i still have some money stuck
in mongols but anyway so um so but i was learning
and playing with it and i really liked it i
i like i come from a technology background also
a financial background trading background so i
understand also like given like traveling between
countries i immediately understood the impact this
could have and then um but i wasn't sure if i was
going to go go all in right so so you but and then
i went to a conference in december in vegas in las
vegas uh in in that conference there was vitalik
there was like charlie lee there was matt rozek
the same crew um uh but that was like a 200 people
conference uh in las vegas and i just thought
that was a really nice group a group of guys
back then the industry is much smaller there's
much less debate and contention that you see on
twitter these days between different blockchains
etc so uh i remember some guy was teaching
me about ripple back then like how to set up
the sort of gateways and stuff like that yeah
and then in the process he transferred like 500 us
dollars worth of ripple to me and then um i said
well now i learned it let me transfer this back
to you so i had i all set up he said just you know
keep it and you can send it to the next guy that
you teach like well that's that's pretty nice um
so it was like a community like that back then
so it wasn't like a it wasn't like a pure pump
and dump or like so it was a really nice community
so after that conference um i went back said okay
i'm gonna quit my job i'm gonna i wanted to do
actually i want to do a crypto exchange back then
in my previous uh startup but the other funders
or the other the other partners said ah no not
not not sure so uh i said okay fine then i'm not
gonna quit and then i'll join the bitcoin industry
um and then a month later i was i began to sell my
house um so started about a couple months later um
so it was early in 2014 i sold it um so this is
when between july and december bitcoin price went
from about 100 us dollars to about 1300 us dollars
um and then it was coming back down by fluctuating
a little bit i was like oh no i got to buy it
quickly before it goes up again so i bought a
600 us dollars average price roughly for for that
one million dollars was pretty hard to get to buy
that that that a month back then um and then price
drops to 200 i stayed there for about two years
so i lost about two thirds of a house for for
a long time um it was mentally uh stressful um
but you know you didn't sell did you no i didn't
say i still have those big ones yeah so oh wow
oh wow strong hands easy you've got strong hands
yeah so those are the bitcoins those are the
bitcoins i have so um i never added more um and
that those are just the bitcoins i have so yeah
so so that's kind of how i got in so yeah that's
so insane i love that the guy was like to you
oh yeah just do 10 and you're there like a few
months later no i'm going to do my whole house
i don't want this house anymore i'm
just going to give it up basically
um yeah plus i quit my job too so i was i
was jumping for like a month or so oh yeah so
you gave up your house and your salary i love that
and that is dedication and you didn't even sell so
with that in mind then you know you're obviously
very dedicated to bitcoin your career is bitcoin
where do you think it's going i'm not going to ask
for a prediction um it's a bit unfair give one if
you feel like it um but jim what are you just what
are your thoughts in general on the market because
you know we thought we were going to see all-time
highs yesterday and we're sort of back down to
16.8 which in my opinion is fantastic numbers um
can't be crying at 16.8 at all but what are your
thoughts uh look yeah i think yeah short-term
price predictions are extremely difficult no
one can do that um but i think longer term so this
is also why i have held on to the bitcoins i have
if you look at things long term um uh look the
industry has so much more room to grow uh i
think like look look at any number today right
so today i think that's probably less than 2.2
percent of population in crypto so it's got at
least 500 x to go uh just by that number from
that single metric it might be 0.1 to be honest
and also um the bitcoin uh the future financial
world with crypto is going to be much bigger than
the fiat financial uh uh side market size this is
similar to you should not evaluate uber's market
size using taxi market size because uber can do
a lot more that taxes cannot do um and you should
not be evaluating i don't know an internet company
using the previous type of companies market
market potential and so crypto can do a lot more
in terms of applications use cases etc um and um
i think it's going to be much much bigger than the
than the current financial uh the future crypto
financial economy is going to be much much bigger
than the current fiat one so that's there's tons
of room to grow and also blockchain can be used
outside of financial uh applications as well um
uh land titles anything that requires proof um
super supply chain management so voting voting yes
loading yeah so like basically this there's a lot
more room to grow uh so i i i think there's like a
couple thousand times room to grow whether that's
bitcoin or not nobody knows but in the short term
i don't think bitcoin is going it's going anywhere
so if you look at a day-to-day basis yes markets
will have uh retractions market will have
fluctuations that's how that's how markets work
that's when you put like i don't know a couple
a couple million people together to trade
that's that's what they do um that's just my
psychology um they don't they don't they don't
trade according to a linear line so um yeah so
like in terms of predictions i think the industry
will get a lot bigger um so i'm not worried about
the price the short-term price fluctuations at
all so that's also why i was able to hold and
that's how that's also why i think this industry
will be the fastest growing industry for the next
few decades so uh and we're not we're not just
here for like two days so we want to we want to
be here for the next 50 or 100 years so yeah we'll
see what happens my final question then for you
um it kind of kind of just linked off the back of
that really do you think that crypto can actually
replace fear seriously a lot of people say you
know we see it working side by side governments
are creating you know central bank digital
currencies so what do you think i think it's
going to take a while so it's not it's definitely
not going to happen overnight and it's not going
to happen too quickly um i think anything that's
that deals with a mass population especially like
uh if we're talking about like everybody in
the world there's like 200 different countries
um a few billion uh population um it's gonna
take a while so um i think it's gonna be like a
at the at the most it's gonna be like one
slowly rising was slowly decreasing i mean
people still use uh uh postal mail today
people still use emails today even though
it's the messenger is pretty pretty popular now
um so i mean um there's there's bicycles there's
cars there's trains there's airplanes so people
still use quite a lot of those different things so
i don't know which situation it's going to be but
more likely it's going to be probably going to be
more similar to uh postal mail versus email though
so i think they will be um i think most likely
by any logical understanding of cryptocurrencies
it is much much better than fiat it has a lot of
properties it overcomes a lot of the difficulties
or or shortcomings of our fiat currencies
so it does have a lot of advantages so um but
i don't think it's gonna happen anytime soon
um there's also a there's a learning curve for
mass population alone even though even if it's
100 better and there are also some deficiencies
in cryptocurrencies as well most people don't
know how to hold cryptocurrencies securely today
i most people cannot like even if you give them
a hardware wallet they don't know how to securely
store the backup so the application is not quite
there yet for mass adoption so it's gonna take
a number of years but those those issues will be
overcome so yeah i'm very polish good yeah i agree
the user experience is something which we sort of
need to up our game on um but it doesn't happen
overnight i totally agree with you cece i want
to thank you so much it's been such a pleasure
um you know we always hear about you you know
you're the founder of finance but we never get to
learn about you um so i want to thank you so much
for taking the time and i know it's late but all
the way in asia and where you are so thank you so
much for coming on it's been such a pleasure yeah
thanks thanks for having us thanks for having me
it's no more working hours for me so anyway not
a problem it's a pleasure yeah thanks so much and
thank you thank you for everyone for tuning in and
we will see you next week on thursday bye bye uh